so when you are giving feedback are
these notes is this in person yeah this
is when i wish we still had the printed
page because i'm so the copy editor i
love scribbling notes in the margins but
sadly i have to do it like on the
computer now so all all like right well
i'm always copy editing also because he
is honestly like the worst it's like he
never learned to write he has no sense
of grammar and spelling is atrocious
let's back a little bit on that I'm
doing that no you don't get popping up
so I'm doing that and then I'm also
taking notes on a separate email of like
page 92 he says XYZ change that to below
wha so it's usually like a very long
email and then I'll call him or we'll
sit down in person and I'll go through
the notes page by page usually it's an
awful process that's pretty true at all
I am but also really fun and
collaborative and we talked through you
know all the ideas and all the
characters and talk about what's working
and what's not working and how you know
I usually have ideas for how you could
be more visual with certain things and
that i always love that stuff it's the
other stuff that I hate yeah did you
take some time to find out what the
approach which approach is best cuz i'm
sure some people have different some
people just like just tell me just give
it to me straight others yeah caught
alone no he always told me to coddle him
i just didn't past tense well no I i do
pas de lis she's much much better at it
now I tell him all the things that I
love in the beginning well now we have a
kid so we're always short on time yeah
now it's a techno she's just like change
that says unless I have to go he's
crying oh yeah
you